finalmente ragazzi siamo ritornati su
una perla ma di quelle proprio
all'ultimo video che ho fatto andavo
fatto uno una perla allucinante si
chiama angri angri led non so se lo
ricordate andava affatto un altro
episodio
io devo impersonare questo povero padre
che ha un figlio e una moglie che ha
sempre la roba in faccia questa roba qua
c'è da sempre pace e tu devi essere il
miglior padre esistente quindi ha già è
vero che devi fare tutto sto casino
mentre guardi la partita e tu quando sei
lontano dal guardare la partita se ti
perdi gol e padre sica case stoffa che
idee geniali devo risolvere le cose in
casa guardando la partita ragazzi cioè
questo è quello che devo fare e bevendo
anche la birra mi pare giusto così per
la birra a press and to drink ok la
birra e la partita abbassano il mio levi
il mio livello di calzatura che ride o
aprirti baratto l'avrei varato lo aperto
la partita e che bella savard in hd a ma
mio figlio è grande
questo fosse un bambino 6x8 lui quale
ancora 8 soprattutto fare il calcolo
amano 40 erano state king non so per 48
a 95 per 66 2030 a posto i compiti fatti
cioè i due matematica le scotte il
reining non ho capito cosa devo fare
devo fare tutto questo nel mentre che
scade il tempo va bene poi ragazzi
diventa questo e questo è niente in
confronto un tutorial sono ubriaco da
vari piatti lava però c'è molto tempo
finiti torna torna torna che stanno
segnando più devi resistere e
l'incazzatura non deve arrivare al
massimo questo è il gioco solo che è
veramente 10 adesso questa veramente
semplice questa cosa avete visto poi più
avanti diventerà impossibile
ce l'ho fatta round complete queste sono
le semifinali perché dalla champions
semifinali va bene adesso mettiamo la
difficoltà
suonano alla porta questa legge di
questa era veramente geniale dimmi
testimoni di geova iscritto miss go and
never con beck
devo scriverlo perchè se no se sbagli di
ricominciare e geniale ci sentissimo
ninja ma che ti suonano metro quadro a
partire c'è stato un cartellino rosso
regala l'arbitro juventino come
possibile perché arbitro da yu gi oh non
mi sono perso con ragazzi perdersi un
gol equivale a perdere la partita
la mia partita perché se perdi un gol
l'incazzatura aumentano in maniera
esponenziale
sti cazzo di piatti che fanno eco tavolo
detto l'ho perso porco demonio beni la
bier c'è un tubo che perde c'è un tubo
che perde dove che perde il tubo ma
porca vacca va tutto adesso anodina
nella stanza del tubo porca eva per il
telefono oppure la mia moglie fa
qualcosa
porca vacca vaio riparato veloce via il
tubo a posto
youtube ha posto no gallo perso
l'ho perso porca mark conta sei secondi
valentino alzati che c'è il telefono che
squilla ma come mi serve all 1 di prima
ancora peggio pronto come trotter che
questa è l'apoteosi di youtube pagine
web
e veramente non avrò mai una famiglia
mike l'ho visto l'ho visto l'ho visto ho
visto sono qua ho visto ok a posto tubo
come mister l'ho visto ero lì per anni
vi serve costituto sono per di porco
demonio non lo sapevo i piatti ma chi
cazzo è che mangia tutto il tempo
maledizione spero non segna un'altra
volta sono proprio no ragazzi porca put
basta
l'ho perso ha perso dice presso il
garage o perche mi sono alzato proprio
mentre hanno segnato incazzatura al
massimo l'incazzatura al massimo
avete rotto le palle aiuto ho perso
prezzo per soldato pfeiffer madonna
zitta ma buona birra nas ha dato la
birra ma salvato la birra ma salvato la
birra benin altra birra
mi sono ubriaca tua morte ok forse no
minchia mio figlio piccolo che piange 17
secondi sono morto alla fine regala sono
morto alla fine
porca vacca chi è che ha consegnato
questo gioco porco il demonio la cia
cava cà figliolo fra liberisti compiti
16 ma perché non schiaccia il primo
fottutissimo numero quale qual è il
problema
stavolta lo prendo forse ragazzi sono
fatto santo iddio ho visto l'ho visto
l'ho visto anche la birra ella dimmi
ottobre 4 6 12 18 18 ok i piatti piatti
piatti piatti veloci a prima che segnano
perfetto ce l'ho fatta guarda come
felice anche nelle foto di famiglia col
bambino proprio non gliene frega niente
trenta secondi tieni maglie tra premio
fatto pronto vodafone
un'edizione che si sporcano di continuo
nessuno sta mangiando come fanno a
sporcarsi ho perso un gol ma fa niente
mancano i secondi teoricamente cioè
dovrei aver fatta bisogna visto di che
ce l'ho fatta vederlo un genio no
ragazzo su tutte era questa la partita è
l'incredibile tutto perché se riuscito a
portare mio figlio ma danno fatto sono
ubriaco contiene o finale finale finale
fermi 300 secondi sei possibile ripetere
cedute con i cosiddetti è già stato un
miracolo arrivare
alla fine del primo riuscirci devo
riuscire al primo tentativo ragazzi ce
la posso fare se mi impegno ce la posso
fare
l'ho visto l'ho visto l'ho visto l'ho
visto l'ho visto l'ho visto l'ho visto
l'ho visto l'ho visto l'ho visto veloce
farvelo vedere perfetto ok mio figlio
cosa vuoi fa novanta brutto strappo me
ho messo tua mark sto scherzando
spett che devo capire un attimo quadro
cullare mio figlio aspetta che forse ho
capito molto bene
[Musica]
certo che se gli fai questo sto verso
non so se sabor mente a jesi ho perso un
altro gol forse ci arrivo forse ci
arrivo ci sono arrivato perfetto per la
birra che quel casino se no eh sì è sì
no no aspetta aspetta
diciamolo perso meno male meno vale a
dire le devo veramente razionare perché
mi danno quella botta in più
ok perfetto togliti a meno che già casey
non fa niente almeno togliti testimoni
di geova di me non è il momento per
miley gesù cristo ha i am going to cloud
di dorna tra l'altro tutto sto casino
nel mentre che ubriaco perché se sei
ubriaco
secondo me è più difficile scrivere
credo non lo so mi sono perso un gol in
tutto questo madonna ragazzi sono
ubriaco se non è più difficile scrivere
ai testimoni di geova quindi non so
tutto sto casino non siamo neanche a
metà partita sono già ubriaco morto
com'è possibile non si vede niente
la si vede più nulla l'ho appena
riparato
non vedo niente oddio no per sul blog
non vedo più nulla sono ubriaco cosa
vuoi che mi fai perdere i gol non ho
momento il paese
se madonna raga mi sta veramente
impegnando non è possibile
no ora che vi sono gara 20 per gli
altissimi ed è bello che quando segnano
dinamico nobara a casa a caso dando ai
degli r in dir
note gol credo nella birra non indici va
bene non so se è considerabile blasfemia
questa non pensa c'è talmente strana ma
st madonna impossibile aspettare cesta
un altro gol ce l'ho fatta la smettete
di suonare al mio cacchio di campanello
basta santo iddio mogli e fai qualcosa
ti supplico cosa c'è ai prelievi in non
ci voglio che lo sbagliato
no ma dai
ce l'ho fatta il ruolo perdo il collo
perdo lo penso mio figlio
suonano il campanello soraga natali ma
neanche a 100 secondi commedia ma lo fa
perché l'ultimo episodio ho vinto non
arriva neanche a 100 è impossibile
l'ultimo e mi sto veramente anche capito
come si culla mio figlio e nonostante
questo sto perde è veramente
difficilissimo l'ultimo è proprio
impossibile la finale non si può fare un
suonato il campanello no cosa vuoi rumor
era tubo che riparato il club che hanno
suonato il campanello predict no no al
momento pare gesù cristo shop banana
corri 95 100 addio
questo è facile da togliere ma secondo
me è uno di quelli che ti crea più
stress in assoluto poi chi ti guarda che
sta qua e non fa niente quella raga 75
secondi devo resistere
dio mio gioco più difficile della storia
aspetta che c'è il tubo che perde
testimoni presentatevi ora se dovete
farlo
ma da una parola ramara corri li vedo
tutti sti ruoli che la partita finita 7
a 0
bellissimo mio figlio che piange secondo
me non mi conviene pagarlo ragazzi todi
cina in un'edizione no non ci voglio
credere
secondo me se mio figlio piccolo non
smette di non ci un gol un gol gol gol
gol gol gol con la birra con la birra
spaccati di birra e il momento di non
pagare fini sulle casse di birra e basta
spaccati divenire bastavano i secondi
praticamente ce l'ho fatta
spaccati di birra ce la fai tanto per
essere padre di famiglia è stato
veramente difficile
signori spero che mi sia piaciuto mi
sarà angri angri dead c'è un gioco
poetico ma un grosso significato vero
non bene tanta birra che poi mette si
unì geova arrivano iscritti al canale vi
prego perché questo lo merita schiaccia
daccapo nellina non quella del
campanello mio perché potrebbe essere un
problema che video cacciare però quella
del canale quella quella del sito e noi
come sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
vi era ragazzi
[Musica]